If I'm allowed to have a favorite forger, which I know sounds a little bit funny, it would be Eric Hebern, who's really the Prince of Art Forgers. He's the only one of over 60 that I look at in my book, who I think is at the same level as the artist he forged. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. On today's podcast, how the brain tells real from fake, when it comes to fine art and fine wine. We start with Noah Charney, author of the Art of Forgery.
如果允许我有自己最喜欢的造假者——我知道这听起来有点好笑，那这个人一定是埃里克·赫伯恩（Eric Hebborn），他堪称艺术造假界的王子。在我书中所研究的60多位造假者中，他是唯一一个我认为其水平能够与他所伪造的艺术家相媲美的人。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。在今天的播客中，我们将探讨当涉及纯艺术和优质葡萄酒时，大脑是如何分辨真伪的。我们首先采访《造假艺术》（The Art of Forgery）的作者诺亚·查尼（Noah Charney）。
We talk about Master Forger, Eric Heber. And his story is one of revenge over monetary gain. That's why he turned to Forgery. He initially had been a failed artist. He couldn't get traction with his own original artworks even though he had some serious talent. And he had been at a flea market and he purchased some drawings that he thought might be of value. He brought them to an art gallery in London and the gallery said, this is pretty good, I'll take it off your hands, not bad. So he sold them and he made a profit so he was quite pleased. But then he came back past the gallery a little bit later and saw that it
我们来聊聊艺术造假大师埃里克·赫伯恩。他的故事与其说是为了金钱利益，不如说是为了复仇。这就是他走上造假之路的原因。他最初是一个失意的艺术家。尽管他拥有不俗的才华，但他的原创作品却始终无法获得认可。有一次他在跳蚤市场上买了几张他认为可能有价值的画作。他把它们带到伦敦的一家艺术画廊，画廊说：“这挺不错的，我买下了，还算凑合。”于是他把画卖了出去，赚了一笔钱，这让他感到相当高兴。但过了一会儿，当他再次路过这家画廊时，他惊奇地发现
was in the window the very object he had sold for much more than he had paid. And he felt that he had been essentially swindled by the gallery and decided to get revenge. And so when you look at Hebron and his reaction to this gallery, he is outraged that the gallery cheated him and that this gallery is part of the artistablishment that has not taken him seriously, has not given him his due. And he makes this life-changing decision. What was the decision? The decision was to try to make his own drawings in the style of old masters and
正是他卖掉的那幅画，被摆在橱窗里出售，价格比他当初卖出的高得多。他觉得自己基本上被这家画廊给诈骗了，于是决定报复。因此，当你审视赫伯恩及其对这家画廊的反应时，你会发现他对画廊欺骗了自己感到愤怒，并且认为这家画廊正是那些没有认真对待他、没有给予他应有评价的艺术建制派的一部分。他做出了一个改变人生的决定。什么决定？这个决定就是尝试模仿古代大师的风格创作自己的画作，
try to pass them off as originals. And by doing so, he gains a sort of passive-aggressive revenge that is the primary initial motivation for the majority of art foragers in this book. And there are two components to it. On the one hand, if he creates a drawing, and the experts think that it's by a great master, then he can convince himself that he must be as good as the master.
并试图将它们蒙混过关当作真迹出售。通过这样做，他获得了一种被动攻击式的复仇，这也是本书中绝大多数艺术造假者最初的主要动机。这里面包含两个方面。一方面，如果他创作了一幅画，而专家们认为这出自某位伟大巨匠之手，那么他就可以说服自己，他的水平一定和这位大师不相上下。
But the second part is that if he's able to fool these so-called experts, he demonstrates how foolish they are, and the implication is that they were foolish not to endorse his own original artworks. When Hepburn decided to forge the great masters, he decided to do it in a way that was quite unique. What was that way? The majority of successful art foragers in the 20th century use variations on what I call a Providence trap, and there are four variations on it.
但第二部分是，如果他能够愚弄这些所谓的专家，他就展示了这些专家的愚蠢，而潜台词是，这些专家当初没有认可他自己的原创作品，本身就是愚不可及的。当赫伯恩决定伪造伟大巨匠的作品时，他决定以一种非常独特的方式来进行。那是怎样的方式？20世纪绝大多数成功的艺术造假者都采用了我所称的“出处陷阱”的变体，这里面有四种不同的变体。
But the essential component is it uses Providence or the documented history of an object as a trap to lure the researcher to authenticate the work. Let's be honest, every art historian wants to be Indiana Jones and wants to find lost treasures. And you may or may not know that the majority of works that we know of made by old masters are lost. In some cases, as much as two-thirds of the of of these famous artists of the Renaissance, we know of them through documented references to them, but we don't know where they are.
但其核心成分是，它利用“出处”（provenance）或一件物品的有据可查的历史作为诱饵，诱使研究人员对该作品进行鉴定。说实话，每个艺术史学家都想成为印第安纳·琼斯（Indiana Jones），都想找到失落的宝藏。你可能知道，也可能不知道，我们所知道的古代大师的作品中，很大一部分其实是失传的。在某些情况下，文艺复兴时期这些著名艺术家的作品有多达三分之二是通过文献记载为人所知的，但我们却不知道它们的下落。
So Providence Trap uses documented history and then creates lost works that match the real documented history. And Eric Hebron is an example of that. He very cleverly created drawings that looked like preparatory sketches for famous paintings. We all know that famous artists throughout history prepared their paintings and sculptures by doing sketches by doing drawings.
因此，“出处陷阱”利用有据可查的历史，然后虚构出符合真实历史记载的失落作品。埃里克·赫伯恩就是这样一个例子。他非常聪明地创作了一些看起来像是著名画作预备草图的画作。我们都知道，历史上著名的艺术家在创作绘画和雕塑之前，都会通过做草图和素描来做准备。
But it was not until relatively recently that drawings were considered a collectible art form and worth keeping. It's a little bit like blueprints and a building. You keep the building, but you don't necessarily keep the blueprints. Eric Hebern would create what appeared to be these preparatory drawings for works like the one I'm looking at in the book right now, Anthony Van Dyke's, Crowning with Thorns, which is in the Museo del Prado and Madrid. He created what looked like a drawing in preparation for that, and we know logically that Van Dyke made lots of preparatory drawings, but they simply aren't extant anymore.
但直到相对晚近的时候，素描才被认为是一种值得收藏和保留的艺术形式。这有点像建筑的蓝图。你会保留建筑物，但不一定会保留蓝图。埃里克·赫伯恩会创作出看似是这类预备草图的作品，比如我书里现在正在看的这幅——安东尼·范·戴克（Anthony Van Dyck）的《荆棘冠冕》（Crowning with Thorns），这幅画现藏于马德里的普拉多博物馆。他创作了一幅看起来像是为该画作做准备的素描，从逻辑上讲，我们知道范·戴克做过很多预备草图，但它们确实已经不复存在了。
I wonder if you could just walk me through these two drawings that I'm looking at in the book here. I'm seeing the original on my left-hand side, and I'm seeing Heberne's preparatory drawing for this work on the right. What am I seeing here in Anthony Van Dyke's crowning with Thorns? In the original painting, which was finished around 1620, is an oil on canvas. It's a substantial size and it shows Christ having the crown of thorns lowered on him as he's bound and he's surrounded by people who would have been his torturers. And he seems resigned to his
我想请您带我仔细看看书中的这两幅画。我看到左边是原作，右边是赫伯恩为这件作品创作的预备草图。在这里，安东尼·范·戴克的《荆棘冠冕》中展现了什么？在完成于1620年前后的原作中，这是一幅布面油画。它的尺寸相当大，描绘了基督被捆绑着，头部被戴上荆棘冠冕的场景，周围围着据信是他的行刑者的人。他似乎对自己的
fate. And it's very beautiful. It's very glossy. There's brilliant use of oil paints. You can have an almost sculptural quality to Christ's body. I'm seeing his face, Christ's face turned to the right from our perspective. I'm seeing there's a figure in the foreground in the right hand side of the painting who's reaching out and touching Christ on his left arm. And there's a host of figures in the background who are doing various things. Right, there are a number of figures, there's one, two, three, four, five figures in the background, including people peering in through a graded window in the back to spine, what's happening and Christ has seated quite comfortably facing front out to the viewer. Now, when we turn to the preparatory drawing, the positioning of the figures and the number
命运逆来顺受。这幅画非常美丽，光泽十足。油画颜料的运用堪称精妙。基督的身体呈现出一种几乎是雕塑般的质感。我看到他的脸，从我们的角度来看，基督的脸转向了右侧。我看到画作右前方有一个人物正伸出手触摸基督的左臂。背景中还有一群人在做着各种各样的事情。没错，背景中有好几个数字……背景里有五个人，包括透过后面的格栅窗向内窥探、想看看到底发生了什么的人，而基督则十分舒适地坐着，面向前方看着观者。现在，当我们转向预备草图时，人物的定位和数量
of the figures is different, but this is entirely normal. Artists, when they're coming up with a concept or invention of the artwork, will do various sketches to try to get a composition that they like. And the composition of this preparatory drawing is actually in the shape of an asset, something called Figura Serpentinata, which was described by Michelangelo as the most beautiful form in nature.
虽然有所不同，但这是完全正常的。艺术家在构思或创作艺术品时，会做各种草图，以期得到他们喜欢的构图。而这幅预备草图的构图实际上呈S形，被称为“S形曲线”（Figura Serpentinata），米开朗琪罗曾将其描述为自然界中最美的形式。
The flickering of a candle flame is supposed to be the positioning of the bodies that is the most elegant, and that's something that we see here in Eric Heberin's forgery of a vandike drawing. And it's normal to have sketches that look somewhat different from the finished product. In fact, it would be suspicious if there was a drawing that looked exactly like the finished product. But here you have this idea that Christ is leaning far to the side, he's being physically supported by one of his executioners, as another one pushes the crown of thorns more violently onto his head. It's more dynamic, and there's more movement to it, more diagonalsals and it essentially looks like
烛火的闪烁被认为是身体最具优雅感的姿态，我们在埃里克·赫伯恩伪造的范·戴克素描中也看到了这一点。草图看起来与成品有些不同是正常的。事实上，如果有一张素描看起来与成品一模一样，那反而会令人起疑。但在这里，你会发现这种构思：基督向一侧倾斜得很厉害，他被其中一个行刑者双手托住身体，而另一个人则更加暴力地将荆棘冠冕压在他的头上。它更具动感，有更多的运动感、更多的对角线条，并且基本上看起来像是一个
Initial concept that you decided not to follow through with for this drawing It's very clever because it's not hitting you over the head with the fact that this must be preparatory drawing What I find really really clever about this was that Herb and was leaving me to complete his con and Hebern was leaving me to complete his con, and there's two things that I found really intriguing there from a psychological perspective. One, when Hebern is basically presenting a preparatory drawing that looks actually quite different from the finished drawing, he's allowing the expert to connect the dots. That is psychologically very clever, because he's taking advantage of the fact the expert has vanity and wants to make these connections. And the best con game is where the mark essentially executes the con for you. That's one of the things he was doing.
最初的构思，只是你决定不在最终的画作中采用它。这非常聪明，因为它并没有生硬地向你灌输“这一定是一幅预备草图”的概念。我觉得这极其聪明的地方在于，赫伯恩在引导我去完善他的骗局，从心理学的角度来看，我有两点深感着迷。第一，当赫伯恩基本上呈现出一幅实际上与成品截然不同的预备草图时，他是在允许专家自己去串联线索。这在心理上非常聪明，因为他利用了专家具有虚荣心、渴望建立这种联系的心理。最高明的骗局，就是受害者基本上替你完成了整个骗局。这是他所做的事情之一。
But the second thing was, by so doing, he's also demonstrating to himself that the expert really is not an expert. That he's demonstrating for his own psychological satisfaction that this world of the art expert is a sham world. It's true, it's very clever on his part, and the majority of successful fordras use some variation on the theme that you describe. They set a trap without being too specific and allow the experts to dive headfirst into it and enthusiastically authenticate the work because it feels to them like a great discovery
但第二点是，通过这样做，他也在向自己证明，这位专家其实根本算不上专家。他在为自己的心理满足感证明，这个艺术专家的世界其实是一个虚伪的世界。确实如此，他这一手非常高明，绝大多数成功的造假者都采用了你所描述的主题的各种变体。他们设下一个并不十分具体的陷阱，然后让专家们一头扎进去，满腔热情地对作品进行鉴定，因为对他们来说，这感觉就像是一次重大的发现
that they are making personally. It feels like a triumph. And once an expert goes out on a limb and says, this is authentic, it is very hard for them to go back on it. So they wind up tangling themselves in this net that's been laid out by the forger. themselves in this net that's been laid out by the forger. What struck me as I was reading this chapter was the extraordinary attention to detail and the effort that Hebern put in to mastering the techniques needed to pass off his works
是他们亲手完成的。这感觉像是一场胜利。一旦某位专家信誓旦旦地宣称“这是真迹”，他们就很难再收回这句话了。因此，他们最终会作茧自缚，缠进造假者布置好的这张大网中。缠进造假者布置好的这张大网中。在阅读这一章时，打动我的是赫伯恩在掌握将其作品冒充为真迹所需的各种技术时所投入的非凡对细节的关注和巨大努力。
as real. Well Hebern was particularly meticulous and of all of the foragers I looked at, he was really the one who was the most passion as an art historian and as a researcher and was focused on getting the materials correct whenever he could. Getting the technique right is something that you can do essentially by practice. You can practice over and over again and you could come up with a signature that looks almost identical to mine and if you practice it enough you can do it with a fluidity that looks authentic. Getting the materials correct is much harder and it's more expensive. It is also not strictly necessary because most forgers that I looked at got the style just about right. They had a very
嗯，赫伯恩格外一丝不苟。在我研究过的所有造假者中，他是真正作为一名艺术史学家和研究人员最具激情的一个，并且只要有可能，他就会专注于把材料弄对。掌握正确的技术基本上可以通过练习来做到。你可以一遍又一遍地练习，最后写出一个几乎和我一模一样的签名；如果你练习得足够多，你就能以一种看起来真实流畅的方式将其写出来。要把材料弄对要难得多，而且成本更高。而且严格来说这并非绝对必要，因为我研究过的大多数造假者都能把风格模仿得八九不离十。他们拥有一个非常
clever provenance trap that was the confidence trick that passed off the object and they didn't really need to get the materials correct because it's not normal for objects to be friendsically tested unless some red flag is raised stylistically or in terms of the object's history. Nobody does forensic testing. This is part of a residual gentleman's agreement in the art trade that dates back hundreds of years that if an expert says it's good, then it's good. There really has to be something very wrong for them to forensically test it. Or maybe the experts disagree. Or if the experts disagree, if they can't reach a consensus, then the tiebreaker is broken
巧妙的出处陷阱，这就是蒙混过关的信任诡计，他们其实并不需要把材料弄对，因为通常情况下，除非在风格上或对象的历史方面出现了某种警示信号，否则物品是不会接受法医级检测的。没有人会去做这种法医检测。这是艺术品交易中延续了数百年的绅士协定残余的一部分——如果专家说它是真的，那就是真的。除非出现了什么非常严重的问题，他们才会去对其进行法医检测。或者也许专家们的意见不一致。如果专家们意见不一致，无法达成共识，那么打破僵局的最后手段
by scientific testing. These days it doesn't have to be the case. Forensic testing is neither particularly expensive nor is it invasive necessarily into the object. But Hebern took that level of detail because he was a perfectionist because he loved what he was doing. He was very passionate about it. And because I think he wanted to genuinely feel that he was doing exactly what the old
就是科学检测。如今情况不一定非得如此。法医检测既不是特别昂贵，也不一定对物品具有侵入性。但赫伯恩追求这种细节水平，是因为他是一个完美主义者，因为他热爱自己所做的事。他对此充满了热情。而且我认为，他希望真切地感受到自己正在做着古代
masters were doing. And he is the only one of all the artists I looked at, all the art forders I looked at, who I think was at a similar level to the people he was forging. When you look at the work that he did where he basically broke down the different colors of the masters were using, how did he actually find this out? I mean, he was spending enormous amounts of time being a scholar, not just being a forger, but being a scholar. He couldn't have done the forgeries
大师们真正在做的事情。在所有我研究过的艺术家、所有我研究过的艺术造假者中，他是唯一一个我认为其水平能够与他所伪造的人相媲美的人。当你看到他的作品时，他基本上拆解了大师们使用的不同颜色，他是怎么发现这些的呢？我的意思是，他花费了大量的时间去当一个学者，不只是作为一个造假者，而是作为一个学者。如果他不做学术研究，他是绝对不可能完成这些造假的。
if he hadn't done the scholarship. He had a bent as a chemist, and he did analyses of the pigments used by different artists. It is so interesting that he spends so much time thinking about his technique, but also thinking about what he needed to do to himself in order to be able to pull off these forgeries. One of the things you talk about in this book is how he achieved this fluidity of line that he was able to forge these things in a way that looked tossed off. What did he do?
他有着化学家的天赋，并对不同艺术家使用的颜料进行了分析。非常有趣的是，他花了那么多时间思考自己的技术，同时也思考为了能够成功实施这些造假，他自己需要做些什么。你在书中谈到的一点是，他是如何实现这种线条流畅性的，以至于他能够以一种看似随性的方式伪造这些东西。他是怎么做到的？
Well, he's a real character, and he volunteered all of his secrets because he was looking for notoriety, and he wrote a book called The Art Forger's Handbook, which incidentally has been found in the studio of many an art forger rested since it came out. And one of his tricks was to get drunk. He would get drunk while he was making the drawings, and it would achieve a certain fluidity of line and body, and the process, he would not overthink things. And when I was giving you the example of if you tried to forge my signature, you wouldn't have the mental or physical capacity if you drink enough to be too painstaking about it. And a painstaking line is a giveaway
嗯，他是一个真正的奇人，由于他渴望出名，他自愿吐露了自己所有的秘密。他写了一本名为《艺术造假者手册》（The Art Forger's Handbook）的书，顺便说一句，自这本书问世以来，许多落网的艺术造假者的工作室里都能搜到它。他的诀窍之一就是喝醉。他在作画时会喝醉，这能让线条和身体达到一种特定的流畅度，在这个过程中，他不会过度思考。正如我刚才举的例子，如果你试图伪造我的签名，如果你喝得够多，你就会失去过分斟酌所需的精神和身体能力。而一笔一划斟酌出来的线条
to an expert that's something funny is going on. He would do dozens of sketches to prepare the fluidity of line he was after, but then he would start drinking heavily and then do his sketches as well in order to ensure that he wouldn't overthink things. So his forgeries were actually committed while he was on the influence of alcohol? Absolutely, and he volunteers this. He actually has step-by-step recipes for how he made his forgeries of paintings and drawings in his book, and that's one of the ways we can work backwards and see, well, if these were the techniques employed by Hebern,
则是向专家泄露“情况不对”的破绽。他会做几十幅草图来酝酿他所追求的线条流畅度，然后他会开始狂饮，接着在醉酒状态下完成素描，以确保自己不会过度思考。所以他的造假实际上是在酒精的作用下完成的？完全如此，他自己也主动承认了这一点。他在书中甚至给出了制作绘画和素描造假的具体步骤配方，这就是为什么我们可以逆向推导并发现：如果这些是赫伯恩采用的技术，
other forders might have used similar techniques. And future forders literally reproduced the recipes that he put into play in his book. I'm really intrigued by the idea that the motivation for so many of these forgers, Hebern included, is not money. So when you think about forgery and the effort and the time it takes to forge a masterpiece, clearly you would think that the financial value, the forger is deriving, it has to be a big part of it. And I'm really intrigued by the idea
那么未来的造假者很可能会使用类似的技术。后来的造假者们甚至直接照搬了他在书中公开的那些秘方。我真的很好奇这样一个观点：包括赫伯恩在内的许多造假者的动机并不是金钱。所以，当你想到造假以及伪造一件杰作所花费的努力和时间时，你自然会认为造假者从中获得的经济价值一定是其中很大的一部分。但我对
that it's really a psychological motivation that comes first. It's true. The reason that many forgers continue into a career of forgery is eventually they realize this is a source of income, but that initial motivation is this passive-aggressive revenge. However, there's a caveat here because the revenge is a private victory until you're caught.
首先起主导作用的其实是心理动机这一观点非常着迷。确实如此。许多造假者之所以将造假生涯进行到底，是因为他们最终意识到这是一条财源，但最初的动机其实是这种被动攻击式的复仇。不过，这里有一个前提，那就是在被抓获之前，复仇只是一种私下的胜利。
And a lot of these foragers have either intentionally made a mistake, perhaps subconsciously, in order to get caught, or quite overtly outed themselves, as in the case of Eric Heppard who published a memoir, and a how-to manual for future forgers. The reason is that they have to enjoy this revenge entirely in private until somebody discovers them, but the moment they are discovered, then all of a sudden they're shown as a great artist, and they have publicly shamed the experts who they were out to shame when they set out. So this is the completion, the self-actualization is only when they're caught. A lot of these
而且，许多造假者要么是有意无意地犯了一个错误，或许是潜意识里为了被抓，要么就是像埃里克·赫伯恩那样非常公开地暴露了自己，他出版了一本回忆录以及一本写给未来造假者的操作手册。原因在于，在被人发现之前，他们必须完全私下里享受这种复仇的快感；但一旦被人发现，他们突然间就被视为伟大的艺术家，并且公开羞辱了那些他们在着手造假时一心想要羞辱的专家们。因此，这种自我实现、复仇的圆满只有在他们被抓时才会达成。这些造假者中的许多人
foragers actually inserted what one forger by the name of Tom Keating called Time Bombs. And these are intentionally inserted anachronisms that could be used if the forger chooses to announce that the work is a forgery, even if no one would otherwise believe him. What's an example? One of my favorite stories is a German forger named Lothar Malscott, who was a Restorer of medieval frescoes just after the Second World War. And was a restore of medieval frescoes just after the Second World War. And he was commissioned to restore frescoes in a church that had
实际上加入了被一位名叫汤姆·基廷（Tom Keating）的造假者称为“定时炸弹”的东西。这些是故意植入的时代错误，如果造假者选择宣布该作品是赝品，即使其他人可能不信，这些也可以作为证据。有什么例子吗？我最喜欢的故事之一是一位名叫洛塔尔·马尔斯科特（Lothar Malskat）的德国造假者，他是第二次世界大战后中世纪湿壁画的修复师。并且他是二战刚结束时的一名中世纪湿壁画修复师。
been damaged by allied bombs. But when he got there, he found that the frescoes were so badly destroyed, there was nothing he could do, and the photographs in the archives didn't show enough to reproduce it. But that didn't stop, and we decided to make his own medieval frescoes. And when they were revealed it was a big national sensation, so much so that the German government
他受委托修复一座在盟军轰炸中受损的教堂里的湿壁画。但当他到达那里时，他发现这些湿壁画损毁得如此严重，他根本无能为力，而档案馆里的照片也没有提供足够的细节来复制它们。但这并没有阻止他，我们决定创作他自己的中世纪湿壁画。当它们被揭晓时，在全国引起了巨大的轰动，以至于德国政府
printed 4 million postage stamps with a detail from the frescoes on it. But he didn't want this private victory, he wanted to get credit for what he had done, and nobody believed him. So he took the very unusual step of suing himself, so that he could have the public forum of a courtroom in which to argue his case that he was the artist of these frescoes. He was both a prosecutor and a defendant. He was.
印制了400万枚带有这些湿壁画细节的邮票。但他不想要这种私下的胜利，他想要为自己所做的事获得认可，但没有人相信他。于是他采取了一个非常不同寻常的举动——起诉自己，这样他就可以在一个公开的法庭论坛上为自己进行辩护，论证自己才是这些湿壁画的创作者。他既是原告又是被告。是的。
It's a very weird case in legal history and still nobody believed him and he pointed out two time bombs that he had inserted intentionally in case no one believed him. One was a turkey. Turkeys are indigenous to North America and there would have been no turkeys in 13th century Germany and second was Marlene Dietrich, whose portrait was hidden in the background and she definitely wasn't around in the 13th century So this is so interesting because of course when you think about stories about swashbuckling Robinhoods the Leaving behind a motif in your crime that you rob a bank and you leave behind a white glove, or you rob something else and you leave behind the same white glove,
这是法律史上一个非常诡异的案件，即便如此，仍然没有人相信他，于是他指出了他故意埋下的两个“定时炸弹”，以防没有人相信他。其中一个是火鸡。火鸡原产于北美，13世纪的德国根本不可能有火鸡；第二个是玛丽莲·梦露（Marlene Dietrich），她的肖像被隐藏在背景中，而她绝对不可能在13世纪出现。所以这非常有趣，因为当然，当你想到那些关于侠盗罗宾汉的故事时，你在犯罪现场留下的一个印记——比如你抢了银行却留下了一只白手套，或者你抢了别的东西却留下了同样的白手套——
the desire to leave a stamp on what it is that you have done changes to some ways from the world of just straightforward crime, where you really want to cover your tracks completely to something quite different. One of the issues here and the reason that foragers are quite happy to be caught in the end is that forgers tend to get very low sentences. Some of them don't even go to jail at all. From a public perspective, there is no fear of art forgers. If you go to a cocktail party, and I whisper to you that this intriguing looking gentleman in the corner is a Ponzi Schumer. You would say, oh, I don't want anything to do with him. However, if I say he's an art forger, you'd be intrigued.
这种在自己做过的事情上留下印记的渴望，在某种程度上改变了纯粹犯罪的世界（在那个世界里，你真正想要的是彻底抹去你的行踪），变成了一种完全不同的东西。这里的问题之一，也是造假者最终很乐意被抓的原因，在于造假者往往只会受到非常轻的判刑。有些人甚至根本不会入狱。从公众的角度来看，人们对艺术造假者并没有恐惧。如果你去参加鸡尾酒派对，我悄悄告诉你角落里这个看起来很迷人、风度翩翩的绅士是一个庞氏骗局的制造者，
You'd probably head straight over and start chatting. I would. They're non-threatening. They're not scary. And there's something to admire in them. And they're these wonderful de-kenzian characters who, you have a sense of them more as a prankster than a real criminal. Is it possible, though, that Hebron's desire for revenge and the psychological forces that
你可能会说：“哦，我可不想跟他扯上任何关系。”然而，如果我说他是一个艺术造假者，你一定会被他吸引。你很可能会直接走过去跟他聊天。我确实会这样。他们是没有威胁性的，并不可怕。而且他们身上有一种令人钦佩的特质。他们就像是那种狄更斯笔下的美妙人物，比起真正的罪犯，你更觉得他们像是个恶作剧者。然而，有没有可能，赫伯恩对复仇的渴望以及驱使他的心理力量，
were driving him kept him from accomplishing what might have actually been his life's work? It's entirely possible, but on the other hand, I think that he would say that his life's work shifted to being the greatest art forger in history. And I think he could make a good case for that. And he's in good company. There are art forgers in my book who include Michelangelo, Luca Giordano, Mark Antonio Ramondi, very famous Renaissance artists who also dabbled in forgery, and he is up there in terms of his physical ability to reproduce another artist's
反而阻碍了他去完成原本可能成为他毕生杰作的成就呢？完全有这种可能，但从另一方面来看，我想他会认为他毕生的成就已经转变为成为历史上最伟大的艺术造假者。我想他完全可以为此立论。而且他并不孤单。我书中的艺术造假者包括米开朗琪罗、卢卡·焦尔达诺（Luca Giordano）、马坎托尼奥·雷蒙迪（Marcantonio Raimondi），他们都是非常著名的文艺复兴时期艺术家，也都涉足过造假，而就其复现另一位艺术家风格的身体能力、以及在研究艺术家现有作品集和精确复制材料方面所付出的心血而言，他完全名列前茅。
style, the care that he put in both the concept of playing with the artist's existing ovga and reproducing the materials in an accurate way. He is a genius but he's a genius at art forgery and I don't think it panned out as a genius of original artistry. No one, Charlie, I want to thank you for talking with me today. This has been a pleasure. Thanks for having me. Noah Charney is the author of the Art of Forgery, the Minds, Motives and Methods of Master Forgers. Coming up, I explore why we find art forgers so compelling and why we like studies that show that wine connoisseurs don't know what they're talking about. Stanford professor Baba Shiv tells us about an interesting experiment.
他是个天才，但他是一个艺术造假天才，我不认为他在原创艺术领域能算是个天才。诺亚·查尼，非常感谢你今天接受我的采访。这真是令人愉快的一次交流。谢谢邀请我。诺亚·查尼是《造假艺术：造假大师的心智、动机与手法》（The Art of Forgery: The Minds, Motives and Methods of Master Forgers）的作者。接下来，我将探讨为什么我们会觉得艺术造假者如此引人入胜，以及为什么我们喜欢那些表明葡萄酒行家其实不知所云的研究。斯坦福大学教授巴巴·希夫（Baba Shiv）将为我们讲述一个有趣的实验。
People always swear that when they taste a high-price wine, the wine actually tastes better, they derive more pleasure from the high-price wine. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. I've asked myself why I find the story of Eric Hepburn so compelling. He was a criminal, but I think of him as a Robin Hood type criminal. Part of it is because, as Noah Charnney said, art crime doesn't disturb us. In fact, as Dennis Leary's detective character in the 1999 movie, the Thomas Crown affair says, the stakes for art crime are pretty low, unless you're a member of the 1%.
人们总是言之凿凿地宣称，当他们品尝高价葡萄酒时，酒的味道确实更好，他们从高价葡萄酒中获得的愉悦感也更多。请继续收听。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我一直在问自己，为什么我会觉得埃里克·赫伯恩的故事如此引人入胜。他是一个罪犯，但我更倾向于把他看作罗宾汉式的罪犯。部分原因正如诺亚·查尼所说，艺术犯罪不会打扰我们。事实上，正如丹尼斯·利瑞（Denis Leary）在1999年电影《偷天陷阱》（The Thomas Crown Affair）中饰演的侦探角色所说，艺术犯罪的风险其实很低，除非你是那1%的富豪。
The week before I met you, I nailed two crooked real estate agents, and a guy who was beating his kids to death. So if some Houdini wants to snatch a couple of swirls of paint, that are really only important to some very silly rich people, I don't really give it in. But there's another reason Hebern is a compelling figure. Most of us don't understand the world of art, and we have the vague suspicion that people who claim
在我遇到你之前的一周，我刚抓了两个腐败的房地产经纪人，还有一个把自己的孩子快要打死的家伙。所以，如果某个“胡迪尼”想顺走几抹颜料，而这些颜料其实只对某些非常愚蠢的富有阶层才有意义，我真的不在乎。但赫伯恩之所以成为一个引人入胜的人物，还有另一个原因。我们大多数人不了解艺术世界，我们隐隐约约地怀疑那些自称
to know what they're talking about are faking it. So Hepburn wasn't just making a fast buck. He was waging a populist war. I sometimes feel this way about people who talk about a bottle of wine that has a hint of briny oyster shell, writing the lacy mousse. That's a natural quote from a recent wine review. Psychological studies show that when you pour cheap wine from an expensive bottle, wine officionato say, ah, that wine has flavors of likely toasted brioche, spun honey and glazed
对艺术了如指掌的人其实是在装腔作势。所以赫伯恩不只是在捞快钱，他是在发动一场平民主义的战争。有时，当看到有人谈论一瓶带有“咸味生蚝壳”风味、写着“蕾丝般的慕斯口感”的葡萄酒时，我也会有这种感觉。这是最近一篇葡萄酒评论中的原话。心理学研究表明，当你把廉价酒倒入昂贵的酒瓶中时，葡萄酒爱好者们就会说：“啊，这酒带有轻微的烤法式奶油面包、手造蜂蜜和糖渍杏桃的风味。”
apricot. Baba Shiv is a marketing professor at Stanford. He recently invited wine connoisseurs to a blind taste test. They refused to show up. Why did they refuse to come? for its Stanford. He recently invited wine connoisseurs to a blind taste test. They're refused to show up. Why did they refuse to come? You have someone who is in Abinia, then supposed to be an expert in tasting wine, and now if I invite them over here, and we find out that they're no different than the novices, then they go through reputation in a way.
巴巴·希夫是斯坦福大学的市场营销教授。他最近邀请了葡萄酒品鉴家参加盲品测试。他们拒绝出席。他们为什么拒绝来？他是斯坦福大学的教授。他最近邀请了葡萄酒品鉴家参加盲品测试。他们拒绝出席。他们为什么拒绝来？你有一个所谓的品酒专家，本应是品酒方面的行家，现在如果我把他们请到这里来，结果我们发现他们的表现和新手没什么两样，那么他们的名声就会因此受损。
Okay, so that totally confirms my view that these connoisseurs weren't really experts. But here's where the science gets in the way of a nice theory. Something happened in Babaschiv's wine experiment that shook my popular sensibilities. The researchers put volunteers in a brain scanner, gave them different wines. These were occasional wine drinkers, not experts. Some wines from five dollar bottles were set to be from a $45 bottle. Other wines from a $90 bottle were set to be from a $10 bottle. The volunteers said that wine from the more expensive bottles tasted better compared to the same wine poured from a
好吧，这完全证实了我的看法——这些品鉴家根本不是什么真正的专家。但科学在这里却开始阻碍一个美好的理论了。在巴巴·希夫的葡萄酒实验中发生了一件事，彻底动摇了我的平民主义直觉。研究人员让志愿者进入脑部扫描仪，给他们喝不同的酒。这些是偶尔喝点酒的普通人，并非专家。其中一些5美元一瓶的酒被告知是45美元一瓶的；另一些90美元一瓶的酒则被告知是10美元一瓶的。志愿者表示，与从据称是廉价酒瓶中倒出的同款酒相比，来自更昂贵酒瓶的酒味道更好。
supposedly cheap bottle. All right, score one for the populace. The wine drinkers were fooled. But here's where it gets complicated. The researchers examined the brain scans of the volunteers. So what we've found essentially is that the area of the brain that codes for pleasure, which is the ventral medial prefrontal cortex, this is the area of the brain that codes for pleasure in real time and has been documented in other studies.
好吧，平民阵营得一分。这些饮酒者被骗了。但复杂的地方来了。研究人员检查了志愿者的脑部扫描结果。所以我们基本上发现的是，大脑中负责编码愉悦感的区域——即腹内侧前额叶皮层（ventral medial prefrontal cortex），这是大脑中实时编码愉悦感的区域，在其他研究中也得到了证实。
And what we've found essentially was that this area of the brain that codes for pleasure in real time shows greater activation when the brain thinks that is tasting a higher price wine, then when the brain thinks that is tasting a lower price wine. The volunteers in other words weren't merely saying the wine from the expensive bottle tasted better because they thought that's what they were supposed to say. The volunteers actually did experience the wine differently, it tasted better because they thought that's what they were supposed to say. The volunteers actually did experience the wine differently. It tasted better.
我们基本上发现的是，当大脑认为自己正在品尝价格更高的葡萄酒时，这个负责编码愉悦感的大脑区域会比大脑认为自己正在品尝价格较低的葡萄酒时表现出更高的活跃度。换句话说，志愿者们并不只是因为觉得“应该这么说”而说昂贵瓶子里的酒味道更好。志愿者们实际上的确体验到了酒的不同，它确实更好喝，因为他们觉得这正是他们被期望感受到的。志愿者们实际上的确体验到了酒的不同。它确实更好喝。
If you have expectations about how much pleasure you're going to derive from, let us say, wine, your expectations actually turn into reality. The difference between a $200 bottle of wine and a bottle that costs $8.99 is only partly about the wine. If paying more for a bottle of wine makes you want to save it for a special occasion, share it with good friends over a meal, save for it, then yes, that bottle of wine will taste better. It's exactly the same with art.
如果你对你将从某种事物（比如葡萄酒）中获得的愉悦感抱有预期，你的预期实际上就会变成现实。一瓶200美元的葡萄酒和一瓶8.99美元的葡萄酒之间的差距，只有一部分与酒本身有关。如果你为一瓶酒花更多的钱，让你想把它留到特殊场合、在聚餐时与好友分享、为它精打细算，那么是的，那瓶酒喝起来就会更好。艺术也是完全一样的。
Forger show us that experts can be fooled, but they also miss something important. The value of a painting is only partly about the painting itself. When you look at a masterpiece, you are looking at paint on canvas, but that isn't all you're doing. You're thinking about Monet's hand holding the paintbrush.
造假者向我们展示了专家是可以被愚弄的，但他们也忽略了一个重要的东西。一幅画的价值，只有一部分来自于画作本身。当你看着一幅杰作时，你看到的是画布上的颜料，但你所做的绝不仅于此。你在思考莫奈握着画笔的手。
You're thinking about history, the passage of time. The meaning of the painting isn't just what's on the canvas, it's what you'll bring to it. When Hebron's preparatory drawings were revealed to be forgeries, the drawings didn't change, but something did change in our mind. Instead of making us think about history and time, the drawings were now merely clever. They stopped being masterpieces. at www.hiddenbrainatnpr.org with the word subscribe in the subject line.
你在思考历史，思考时间的流逝。一幅画的意义不仅在于画布上的内容，更在于你为它倾注了什么。当赫伯恩的预备草图被揭露为赝品时，画作本身并没有改变，但我们心中的某些东西改变了。这些草图不再让我们联想到历史和时间，而仅仅变得聪明。它们不再是杰作了。
You can also listen to my stories on your local public radio station. I'm Shankar Vidantan and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以通过访问 www.hiddenbrain.org 并将主题行设为“subscribe”来订阅我们的节目。您也可以在当地的公共广播电台收听我的节目。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这里是NPR。当前该剧集尚无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。